good morning everybody live from wigan
the uk is in the midst of a cost of
living crisis and this morning we can
bring you some exclusive data
commissioned by sky news which reveals
the extent to which people are
struggling and it makes for very stark
reading we're going to be putting those
questions to the minister in just a
moment this week and we're going to find
out how how people in this town are
being impacted here at my old primary
school at beach hill it's been rebuilt
since i was here 50 years ago let me
tell you nearly half of the kids are on
free school meals
over two thousand people we surveyed
across britain
more than four in five eighty-four
percent say they are concerned by the
rising cost of living over the next six
months
sixty-five percent of people have
switched off their heating to lower
their bills we're told 27 say they have
skipped meals as they can't afford to
eat and more than half that's 52
are socializing less 44 percent of
people are also driving less than they
did before with 31
working from home more to save cash
almost a third are cutting back on tv
and streaming to reduce costs and one in
five people 19
have even borrowed money to make ends
meet
well the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis is with us now mr lewis
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you very much indeed
uh let's start with our uh exclusive
polling should we uh 76 of all voters 71
7 out of 10
tory voters do not think that this
government is doing enough to help them
uh in these incredibly challenging times
with the cost of living your thoughts on
that this morning secretary of state
well one of the things i see is a
constituency and peers members of
parliament across country will see some
of the challenges that our constituents
are facing and we all have energy uh
prices that we deal with whether it's
heating our own homes and talking to our
constituents about the challenges they
face so i absolutely recognize that that
challenge that people are seeing out
there i have to it's why the chancellor
the prime minister put in place that big
package just a few weeks ago in reality
about 22 billion package some wishes
already come into place with the changes
that came through in april we've also
got more changes coming through that
threshold change for national insurance
it's going to make
people better off that comes through in
july as well as the further support for
energy uh later this year but as the
chancellor said we do recognize this as
a challenge and that's why he keeps
these things under review so that we can
look at what can we do and do as much as
we can as i think we've shown through
covid as a government we're prepared to
do to help people where the government
can recognizing that this is a really
big global challenge that we are seeing
around the world at the moment
we're hearing from action for children
they're telling us that at least one
child that they know of i'm sure there
are others had chill planes so
the house couldn't be heated enough he
couldn't go to school because this cat
this kid had chill planes
well nobody wants to hear that kind of
challenge we all want to ensure that
people can look after themselves their
families children and
and other members of their family and
indeed our wider communities and as i
say that's why we've put in place this
package reforms we've got including the
reduction in fuel duty one of the
challenges actually with the issues
we're facing northern is not everything
the chancellor did could be transferred
to support people in northern ireland
due to the protocol but we want to do
what we can to support people but there
is a global pressure on energy prices
we've seen that we understand that but
as a government we will continue to look
at what we can do and the chancellor
does keep these things under view but as
i say there is a 22 billion pound
package of support already in place some
of which
comes further into into support for
people in july this year
and what do you say to people who say
this party this government is just
completely out of touch we interviewed
one of your colleagues yesterday from
the home office two million people have
viewed her comments online so far when
she told me yesterday morning that
people should either work longer hours
or get a better job that is not to
understand the challenges that some
people in britain face this morning
well as i said i think we do recognize
those challenges not just as a
government but all of us as constituency
mps and people with friends and family
who we talk to all the time and
understand what those challenges are i
think the point the ratio to be fair if
you look at the wider interview and what
rachel has outlined is as a government
we are looking to develop an economy
that allows better paid jobs more
productivity we're seeing more people in
work even than we saw before kovid but i
absolutely understand and accept that
doesn't move away from the challenges
that people are facing today uh the
challenge we're seeing globally we're
not the only country in the world
dealing with this issue and that's
something the chance as i say does keep
under view and we have put in place a
substantial package of support 22
billion pounds worth and i would say if
you look at our track record through the
challenging times we had through kovid
where we put that huge amount of support
in whether it's the furlough scheme and
support for businesses among other
things i think we have got a good track
record of doing everything we can to
soften some of these challenges that
people face and i know the prime
minister is determined to continue to
look at these things with the chancellor
to do everything we can
how can somebody who's working for the
nhs where we all went outside to applaud
for them because of the incredible work
that they were doing during the pandemic
how can we ask them to work even longer
hours which is what the minister was
suggesting yesterday
well as i say i think if you look at the
wider interview and the whole of what
she was outlining yesterday what rachel
was outlining was this work that we are
doing through big investments and
support for people making
development to ensure that we get a
higher productivity economy more jobs
available we have got more people in
work than we had even before covered so
there's more opportunity for people out
there that's part of ensuring we put
more money in people's pockets as well
as this huge package of support that the
chancellor has put in place but that
doesn't shy away from the challenges
people okay around the world and we
understand that
not my question minister my question is
how can people who are already working
their fingers to the bone for the nhs to
keep us as healthy as we possibly can be
and to look after us when we're sick how
can we ask them to work even more hours
which is exactly what the minister said
yesterday
well look as i say i think to be fair i
think what rachel was outlining was a
wider issue across the economy for
people not a particular area and look
what we are doing for people who are
should work more hours minister yes but
she's talking across the whole economy
yes but she's talking across the whole
economy and us making available for
people those opportunities obviously
quite right okay some industries and in
some sectors people will already be
working very long hours
for the jobs that they do whether it's
in the public sector or elsewhere and
that's why we've put in this it's a
package of support the 22 billion pounds
of support to help people so that they
are paying obviously we've got that uh
reduction in the threshold for national
insurance that will help people with
hundreds of pounds a year the reduction
in fuel duty all of these changes we are
making doing what we can to ensure that
people have more money in their pocket
to deal with these global challenges
that we're seeing well it's not working
minister it's not working are the poor
just not working hard enough is that
what we're telling them
no it's not what i'm saying at all if in
fact if you look at what i've just said
it's quite the opposite we absolutely
recognize how hard people are working
across the economy with more people in
work than we had before kovid that's why
the chance was put in place a 22 billion
pound package of support to help
individuals we're also putting in
support through that system that we've
that i've outlined already to
help companies develop more jobs for
those who want them and those who need
them and we are always keeping these
things under view as we do through kobe
this is a global challenge it's
something the chancellor has already
said that he is very focused on he will
continue to keep under views as we do at
all times to look at what more we can do
through the course this year where it is
appropriate and where the government can
afford to do that to help people as i
say i think our track record over the
last few years have put in support
wherever we can and how we can is a good
one and i think that does show that we
are determined to help people where we
can and in any way that we can
dr liam fox calling for the uh treasury
committee to launch an investigation
into why the bank of england so
comprehensively in his words
underestimated the inflationary threat
to the uk do you agree with that
well i'm not the bank of england is
quite rightly independent it will remain
independent what the treasury select
committee do is a matter of them to look
at select committees look at a whole
range of things so i'm not going to
comment the independence of the bank of
england what i would say um is that of
course we are seeing a pressure on
inflation around the world we're still
in the uk below the us pretty much in
line with what we're seeing across
europe actually slightly below europe as
a whole but that doesn't shy away from
the reality of the pressures that higher
inflation is putting on people and on
people's pockets and as i say that's
something the chance i know he's focused
on that's why we've put this package of
support in there while we are seeing
this global pressure on inflation
how helpful is it for the uh governor of
the bank of england andrew bailey to use
words like apocalyptic when he's uh
talking about a global food shortage who
does that help
well as i say i think look what the
banking as an independent body say is
obviously a matter for them i think we
all recognize there is this pressure and
a challenge i think as the governor
outlined yesterday we also particularly
see
pressures on food due to the war in
ukraine and putin's invasion of ukraine
because ukraine is such a big
producer of certain products that go
through into the agricultural industry
and the food sector more generally that
is something that the whole world is is
feeling the side effects from and we are
conscious of that as i say that's why
there is a pact of support out there and
it's why we're looking to do everything
we can as we move forward and these
things don't happen overnight but that's
why the chancellor's put packages in
there and the business secretary and
defra as well department of food and
rural affairs to support more food
security for the uk as we go forward as
well
yeah but when i heard a word like
apocalyptic yesterday
i thought goodness me and i can afford
to feed my family uh what did you think
when you you heard the wood
well i think it does outline the kind of
what they obviously recognize as a and
they see as a challenge for the future
as i say i was somewhat surprised to see
that particular turn of phrase because
obviously we can all see that uh prices
can can move we've seen over the last
few months prices can move one way or
another relatively speedily but we will
be doing what we can to put that support
in there as i say for people across the
country we do recognize there's a
challenge this is not a straightforward
challenge to deal with it's a global
challenge
but it is one that i know the chancellor
is very very focused on no i understand
i understand but you know somewhat
surprised i mean that's an
understatement for people here in wigan
who can't put afford to put food in
their kids bellies at the best of times
another being told by this big geezer in
in london that food uh the shortage of
food is going to be apocalyptic
well it's uh it's not i can't answer for
the bankrupting is independent what
andrew um outlined as the governor of
the banking thing about that i'm asking
you about the word you ask me what i
think of what he says
are you asking me you ask me what i
think of what he said it is a matter for
the bankers
it's not for me to comment on what they
said other than say yes i was surprised
to see that kind of terminology there
particularly in light of the fact that
obviously food supplies are for
supermarkets one of the things i know
again from the work we're doing on the
north line of protocol is supermarkets
food suppliers are ordered and bought a
long way in advance so supermarkets are
already now placing orders for many many
months down the line for certain
products and they're working on today's
prices and what they're buying for today
is what we will be seeing in the
supermarkets in the period ahead as i
say when i'm dealing with supermarkets i
have to say at the moment their main
focus is around how they move products
from great britain to northern ireland
but as i say we are very very conscious
of the challenges that people are facing
both in the uh energy prices that we're
seeing when people are uh whether it's
filling up their car or filling up their
oil tank there on oil at home as they
are in most of my part of the world in
norfolk
we are conscious of that and as i say
that's why that package of support is
there and we will continue to do what we
can while dealing with this global
challenge
okay well let's try another one see if
you're more comfortable commenting on
this one draconian that was the word
that the prime minister used yesterday
when he went to northern ireland you're
brief of course he says that he didn't
think the northern ireland protocol
would be implemented in such a draconian
way
um your view on that and what his trip
achieved yesterday
well it was it was a
really good trip it was good to have the
prime minister we met with five of the
party leaders he also was visiting
thailand who have played such an
important part in belfast through that
playing its part in supporting the
efforts of the amazing people of ukraine
uh as well as visiting the jewish
communities who had a very good visit
yesterday talking to all the party
leaders about getting storm on back up
and running getting a speaker elected in
the first instance and getting the full
executive upper money is obviously uh
where my focus is and what we were
talking about yesterday and the prime
minister is absolutely right in what he
outlined around the eu the
implementation that they're using uh and
that they want to see and let's remember
what the eu's arguing for at the moment
is to have more uh restrictions than we
even have today in northern ireland with
the uh protocol that just doesn't work
it doesn't work for business it doesn't
work for anybody in northern ireland and
one thing that all of the party leaders
were
unanimous about yesterday is what the
protocol needs to be fixed there are
problems with the protocol and we are
determined to do what we need to do to
do that preferably by agreement with the
european union
just to clarify have you pulled back
from introducing legislation to
override the protocol hearing the latest
from liz trust saying that it'll happen
in the summer
we've always said that we hold nothing
off the table we keep everything on the
table to make sure that we can do what
we need to do to ensure the people in
northern ireland have the same rights
and access to goods as anybody else
anywhere in the united kingdom at the
moment the eu are requiring these checks
to be put onto goods that are not going
into the eu we absolutely respect and
always will the need for checks for
products that are moving into the eu but
they're doing it for products at the
moment and they want to go further with
products that are not moving into the eu
that just doesn't work it's not
acceptable we have challenges already uh
we've obviously got challenges we get
installment up and running around the
protocol with the unionist community all
the unionist leaders having issues with
the protocol and all leaders of all
parties wanting parts of protocol
resolved and fixed so that's something
that they're unanimous about so we take
nothing off the table we would like to
get an agreement with the eu but the
foreign sector will be setting out later
today further details around the next
steps for us
is that a yes
well it's a yes in that we take nothing
off the table and as i say we've got a
cabinet meeting in just an hour or so a
couple of hours time and the foreign
secretary will be setting out the our
next steps on how we deal with these
issues for the people of northern
ireland and the wider uk because it's
over 200 businesses in great britain now
not supplying northern ireland due to
the protocols this is something affects
everybody and we want to make sure we
resolve that and the foreign sector will
be setting out as i say following the
cabinet discussion today those details
later today
but that's not going to happen this week
because we were led to believe last week
that this week that uh parts of the
protocol were going to be
i was going to say got rid of i was
going to say rip shop you probably use
that say that was evocative language but
the protocol was likely to be changed
this week that's what all the mood music
was suggesting having been to northern
ireland the prime minister are we saying
now that potentially that is not going
to happen until the summer at least
until well
something like that this week was never
uh on the cards we're still debating the
queen's speech and we won't finish
debating the queen's speech and voting
on that uh until a bit later this week
later tomorrow so that was in that sense
that was never on the cards what we've
always said is that we will not take
anything off the table we would do what
we need to do to ensure that products
can move to northern ireland in the way
they should be able to move to northern
ireland from great britain as part of
the united kingdom's eternal market
something the protocol itself says it
will respect at the moment is not
working properly we would like to do
that by agreeing with the eu but as i
say we we reserve the right to do what
we need to do to do the right thing for
the people of northern ireland and the
wider united kingdom
before i let you go secretary of state
um i thought for the good people of
wigan this morning and this school where
i um was first educated 50 years ago
this is where you say i don't look this
old
oh well it's great to be able to speak
it's always good to know to be able to
go back and visit a school you went to
before and see how it's changed i've
done that myself recently and it's
always slightly surreal to walk around
even if they've changed a lot those uh
those hallways that we walked around
some years ago not that long ago to be
fair but um
and i know that it's it's always uh
as i say an interesting thing to see how
things move on and it's really good to
be able to see
people around the country having that
opportunity through shows like this and
what you're doing carrying your team to
express the experiences they're having
and that's something i think is
important that all of us across the uk
can learn from what each other
experiencing and seeing in our local
communities
okay it's great to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining us
secretary of state always a pleasure
thank you